[Musique]
dernier paris-montréal atterrissage du
boeing 777 avec ses 450 passagers
[Musique]
les pompiers de l'aéroport lui offre le
traditionnel salut au jet d'eau pour son
dernier vol
la famille aussi filmé l'événement et
voici jean lapointe qui apparaît dans la
zone des arrivées à ses côtés sa
conjointe nathalie couet agents de bord
qui a demandé à travailler sur ce
dernier vol ainsi se termine la carrière
de jean lapointe chez air canada
quarante années service c'est sûr que ça
va me manquer mais quelle belle chance
quelle belle opportunité quatre volets
quadriller la planète terre l'eau
pendant ces années là ce fut vraiment
fantastique
pourquoi jean lapointe a choisi de
devenir pilote quand est-ce que
l'histoire commence vraiment l'histoire
si on la faisait commencé à rome
il y à 85 ans et décidons que c'est
italo balbo ministre de l'air sous
mussolini qui a tout déclenché
[Applaudissements]
à
1933 ce monsieur belle bourre réalise un
projet fou il prend la tête d'une
escadrille de 24 hydravion s'envole de
rome pour se rendre à chicago où se
tient une exposition universelle
on veut montrer au monde ainsi que
l'italie sous mussolini et d'un pays
moderne une grande puissance les avions
de gbagbo doit faire plusieurs années
don à shediac au nouveau brunswick et
attention
les appareils se posent sur le saint
laurent du côté de longueuil italo balbo
est accueilli par des sympathisants
fasciste de montréal et cochez cadre les
hydravions repartent de lendemains pour
chicago
as cours dans le bas saint laurent y'a
un p'tit gars de 11 ans qui est
émerveillé par l'expédition de balbo il
s'appelle paul émile lapointe
c'est le père de jean lapointe la
seconde guerre mondiale devient pour lui
une opportunité
paul émile lapointe devient pilote de
spitfire ironie pour aller combattre les
fascistes qu'il avait inspiré à devenir
pilote
c'est lui que l'on voit ici en italie
entre deux missions il a 21 ans
c'est encore lui seul francophone de son
escadrille canadienne pour aller me
lapointe a effectué deux cent onze
sorties un spitfire participé à de
nombreuses attaques de trade qu'on voit
ici on voit que le 25 avril 1945 donc
quelques semaines avant la fin du
conflit
dommage quatre camions ayant détruit 2
son fils jean lapointe a conservé le
carnet de vol de son père après sa
dernière sortie il écrit kaput
c'est fini il n'utilise expression
allemande capote
je reviens au canada après 3002 de cambo
devrez match difficile
paul émile lapointe revient au canada il
va faire deux choses importantes
il sera co fondateur des rimouski qui
deviendra québecair un joueur majeur
dans le transport aérien au québec
ensuite il va se marier avec anne-marie
duret et ils vont avoir cinq enfants il
habite tout à côté de l'aéroport de
rimouski et nous y voilà
le père transmet la passion de
l'aviation à ses enfants alors à 80
notre lit et un avion une trottinette et
vion il y avait des petits avions à
coller partout dans la maison et surtout
c'est que notre mère allait chercher
souvent le paternel l aéroport après ces
vols est déjà là on était imprégné des
odeurs d'huile des odeurs d'essence et
du retour du pilote alors c'est quelque
chose qui frappe et d'un tri maginot
très jeune il a dit très jeune j'ai eu
ma licence de pilote privé à 16 ans va
mon permis de conduire de voiture c'est
pas tout ce sont les trois fils lapointe
qui sont devenus pilotes guillou pour le
service aérien du gouvernement du québec
paul pourade oui tu es gens pour air
canada une maman et arrière grand maman
de 92 ans fier de son fils et de toute
sa famille
sa venue est inquiète pas mal quand même
il ya eu des moments où le début de
l'aviation sur tout
ça c'est à quelle chance pour l'instant
il n'y a pas de relève comme pilote chez
les lapointe
mais qui sait ce que fera la prochaine
génération il a bien fallu dire adieu
aux pompiers de l'aéroport aux
contrôleurs aériens et au personnel de
bord de l'immense boeing 707 la retraite
comment ce pour jean lapointe
au menu de l'amour
[Applaudissements]